so Total Recall is one of the most
beloved science-fiction films of the
last few decades and this ambiguous
ending has led audiences to wonder was
Quaid dreaming or was he actually a
secret agent he is the ending of Total
Recall explain one of the most important
facts of the movie is that the plot of
Total Recall identically mirrors the
memory implants that Doug Quaid Himself
requests from the recall organization
Quaid asked for the secret agent package
I don't want to spoil it for you Doug
but you rest assured by the time the
trip is over you get the girl kill the
bad guys and save the entire planet
coincidentally Quaid realizes he was
always a secret agent yes the girl kills
the bad guy and saves MAS Quaid appears
to wake up before the implant is
actually inserted but the salesman is
very specific about the realism of the
implants and how they trick the brain
into thinking as remembering the real
memories is quite dreaming or just
remembering his true self the blurring
of reality and dream continues
throughout the movie with multiple
villainous characters begging him to
question where he believes to be the
truth
surprisingly the villains are 100%
correct Quaid is streaming on the moment
the camera cuts away from the start of
the recall procedure everything that
follows is our visual impression of
Quaid stream in fact many of the movie's
plot elements are cold directly from
innocuous moments embedded in those few
opening scenes the recall employees even
say that they combine the base program
with elements from the subjects real
life to better create realistic memories
the movie opens with a dream as Quaid
sees himself and the woman will later
learn as Molina on Mars in spacesuits
Quaid slips and falls down a hill and
his helmet breaks his eyes bulging out
of his skull as he wakes up ending the
dream at the end of the film equator
Molina is sucked out into the atmosphere
of Mars and his eyes bulge out of his
skull in almost the same way the Ricoh
scientists are using Quaid streams for
potent imagery the better to matches
subconscious desires with his recall
implanted memories even if Quaid is
actually Houser on a deep secret mission
it makes no sense to him to dream his
own death in a way that looks identical
to what actually happens Quaid Streaming
death scene is foreshadowing for the
final action set piece of Mars a
viscerally effective image that the
scientists used to make the recall
sequence feel even more real
this after overlooked detail is one of
the strongest pieces of evidence that
Quaid is streaming in the opening scenes
prior to the recall procedure he walks
through an x-ray machine we see his
skeleton move through the box without
alerting anyone of any hidden metals on
his body later after the recall
procedures begun and Quaid is running
for his life he passes through the x-ray
machine again this time setting off an
alarm as he recognizes the gun he's
holding however attentive viewers to
remember that Quaid actually has a
tracking chip burrowed in his cranium
but he then has to remove to cast off
his pursuers the tracking chip is
clearly made of metal but didn't appear
in the x-ray either before or after the
recall procedure why not
because Quaid hadn't yet gotten to that
moment in his dream the scientists used
the memory of his stroll through the
machine as an action set piece but
because Quaid didn't know at the time he
had a tracking chip his subconscious
minds didn't bother to change the
imagery of his skeleton early in the
film one of quoits co-workers from the
construction company wants him to not go
to recall he heard someone was almost
lobotomized there Quaid ignores his
warning after the recall procedure he
discovers that his former friend is
actually an undercover agent for the
government has to keep Quaid unaware
bird is he his warning about the
possibility of a lobotomy echoes
throughout the visual inspirations of
the movie when Quaid pulls out his
tracker chip he pushes at or through his
nasal cavity until he hears a crunch a
strikingly similar process to original
lobotomy procedures likewise when a
doctor shows up on Mars to tell Quaid
he's having an adverse reaction to the
recall procedure he takes the tack of
reminding Quaid of the possible
side-effects to the brain when co Hagan
is planning to swap Quaid's memories
with houses the terror of the scene is a
Quaid's personality will be erased a
terror shared by similar horror stories
of lobotomies even quaint AI boating
near death scene at the end of the movie
can be read as a fear of a brain
aneurysm the dangers of the recall
procedure reverberate through the entire
film when Quaid is discussing the recall
procedure with the salesman Bob MacLean
MacLean mentions their special package
this process involves taking on a new
identity and Quaid bristles against it
he still wants to be him but he's
tempted by the secret agent option he
eventually takes it once much
gives him the hard sell but his initial
discomfort of being someone else become
sublimated into the recall procedure
quite as we find out later in the film
is also Howser
a secret agent and one of co Hagen's
right-hand men Wade has to struggle
against being we implanted with houses
personality perfectly mirroring his own
discomfort with the recall procedures
multiple identities option crane wanted
to remain true to himself while still
taking advantage of the secret agent
module of the recall procedure and that
manifests in his battle with the Hauser
personality Hauser allows him to be both
a secret agent deepened to cover while
still remaining the same person he was
before being woke up from that deep
cover Malina is a mysterious woman who
first appears in Quaid stream that opens
a film she's given no dialog or
personality just a face in an astronaut
suit later when Quaid goes to recall
they ask him to describe his perfect
woman encouraging him to be as honest as
possible to have more fun in the
implanted memories Quaid describes a
woman who is quotes brunettes athletic
sleazy and demure and before he passes
out he sees at the scientist a sculpting
Molina's face we know from the beginning
that the scientists are combing through
Quaid's dreams to better fit him for an
implants while Molina's face appearing
on the television could be interpreted
as Quaid's hallucination we know it to
be a product of the scientists
technology Melina herself as we later
find out works in a brothel is athletic
and his poise demure and sleazy she
perfectly matches a personality type
Quaid wants to appear in his recall
memories Laurie Quaid's wife is a games
recall and Mars altogether when Quaid is
enacting his secret agent fantasy he
imagines her as a mole for Co Hagen that
he positions her as a villain when she's
so against him wasting money on a
dangerous procedure or a vacation to a
war zone makes perfect sense her
convenient secret marriage to Co Hagen's
lieutenant Richter a lousy way to freely
pursue milena
without having to worry about any sort
of guilt for breaking his marriage vows
as an added bonus that she consistently
compliments his masculinity and sexual
prowess even when she's an enemy Wade
can't help a user to prop up his own ego
while the sales agent boasts equate that
recall implants are better than a
regular vacation he lists a litany of
annoyances that their service avoids you
got lost luggage
lousy weather crooked taxi drivers
when you travel with recall everything
when quaid-e-azam ours later in the film
he gets a ride from the ultimate crooked
taxi driver Benny a cabbie who had to
deal with a specific establishment that
gives him a cut of the profits if he
brings tourists there but that's not all
later in the film
Benny is revealed as a double agent for
Co Hagen TAS for discovering the secret
mutant freedom fighters lair
Benny's presence serves as a balm for
Quaid's worried mind if this were a real
recall procedure then there wouldn't be
any crooked cabbies just like MacLaine
explained earlier in the film by the
time Quaid reaches Mars his mind has
started to protect him from the
possibility that the recall procedure is
going very wrong lorry shows up again
when Quaid is confronted by dr. ESMA who
warned Quaid he's in danger of suffering
a schizoid embolism and he's trapped
within the dream he says he and Laurie
the real actual mrs. Quaid have gone
into Quaid's fantasy to pull him out
before further damage occurs he wants
quite that the recall fantasy will
become so jumbled that the quote walls
of reality will break down one minute
you'll be the savior of the rebel cause
and the next thing you know you'll be Co
Hagen's bosom buddy you'll even have
fantasies about alien civilizations
Edgemar continues to say that if this
fantasy continues paid will be
lobotomised back on earth quais things
Edgemar is a plant and shoots them both
but the doctor is right the walls of
reality and the hotel literally break
down as Co Hagen's men burst in shortly
after the mutant leader Kuato is
murdered leaving Quaid as the leader of
the rebellion just as ko Hagan bursts in
to deliver the news that Quaid is
actually Hauser his right-hand man the
doctor's prediction was exactly right as
the scientists are preparing Quaid for
the recourse eager in the beginning of
the film one of them notices something
odd in Quaid streams he tells the other
lab worker Ernie he's referring to the
blue sky that ends the film just as
Quaid wonders if he's actually dreaming
and he is the scientists have never
heard of a blue sky on Mars before they
put Quaid under and their acknowledgment
of its significance as what allows them
to create a soothing ending for Quaid's
Rico dream
likewise in the lab seen the secret
alien arc reactor can be spotted
flashing across the screen before
Quaid's put under one of the scientists
also makes the observation that quote
it's all about alien
facts these days it makes no sense for
the recall offices to actually have
access to the alien artifacts that Co
Hagan is obsessed with keeping to
himself it appears on the monitor
because it's part of Quaid streaming
package and they're prepping the
operation director Paul Verhoeven
himself backed that up on the DVD
commentary saying all the images of the
tubes that you just saw are of course
the tubes that you see at the end of the
movie when the nuclear reactor starts
but if all of that evidence can't
convince you there may be the director's
words well Paul Verhoeven lays out the
clues a point to the dream
interpretation on the DVD commentary of
the movie starting at the moment that
Quaid you have soft to sleep after
seeing Molina's face on the monitor be
aware that if everything that happens in
the movie from now on is going to be a
dream if there is no reality to anything
realize that the dream really starts at
the moment that he falls asleep so the
next scene which seems to be a cup of
the machine is part of the dream but
Hoeven continues so this is the last
moment of his reality goes into the
unconsciousness and basically from now
on boom that dream starts that's the
trick of the company that they make a
dream that's so convincing that has
seamlessly goes from the first reality
into the second one check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and at the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]